it's been an election unlike any other
and it could be an election night
unlike any other two let me just show
you why of course
this is all about this the race to 270
electoral college votes it's not just
about winning the most
number of votes across the country it's
about winning in the right places places
like california which has
55 electoral college rates usually goes
democrat texas
usually those republicans 38 votes there
and then over here you can see florida
down there with 29
very important and pennsylvania now what
are we going to do to give you
the full detail about what's happening
we're going to look at
state level about what's happening with
those returns and what's happening
in terms of who's voting for who last
time around of course florida went for
donald trump but could it turn it has
been the decisive state in so many
elections
going back for decades but so too has
pennsylvania last time around donald
trump one in pennsylvania winning it off
the democrats
if joe biden can win it this time well
that could prove very much decisive but
here's the thing they take a long time
to count in pennsylvania so how will we
know
on the night into the morning what's
actually happening and the answer is
we're going to dig down
a little bit deeper we're going to go
into county level data so for instance
here we are in florida this is results
from last time around but have a look
that's the whole state look at miami
dade you see it was democrat last time
but the big question this time is
whether joe biden can win more votes
from voters in that urban area
of florida so many different stories
playing across the state we'll have you
all of them and also look at this
pennsylvania here erie county they're in
the north
of pennsylvania we're going to look at
that because that's a rural county
many white working-class voters went for
donald trump last time around
but can joe biden win it back that could
prove the determining factor
in pennsylvania we'll have all the data
for you all of these results
as our map populates through the course
of the night and indeed the morning
on this the most exciting of all
election nights